we can't afford just to take her around
the edge it's a tax credit here a
regulation there our fight is for big
structural change Elizabeth Warren wants
the federal government to provide free
health care for every American college
for every student who wants it child
care for every parent and housing for
low-income families and she wants to pay
for it all with a new tax on the richest
of the rich she calls it the ultra
millionaire tax skimming a bit more off
the top of the bank accounts of the
ultra wealthy might sound like a good
deal for working in middle-class
Americans who feel like they're falling
behind but the reality is that wealth
taxes have been tried before and they
haven't worked the way that Warren
promises here's what Warren wants to
levy a 2% annual wealth tax on all
households with a net worth over 50
million dollars and a 3% annual tax on
those households with net worth over 1
billion dollars all I'm asking for is a
little slice from the tippy tippy top a
2 or 3 percent tax on multimillionaires
and billionaires
might not sound like much I got a pitch
in two cents and two cents on every
dollar after that wealth taxes are
different than other taxes like say an
income tax or a sales tax which tax
money when it moves around a wealth tax
on the other hand tax is the same pot of
money every year meaning that over time
it becomes smaller and smaller it's
essentially a tax on large savings the
money that investors and entrepreneurs
rely on to start new businesses but I do
think a system that allows billionaires
to exist when there are parts of Alabama
work where people are still getting
ringworm because they don't have access
to public health is wrong unlike
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez Warren has
never said that the existence of
billionaires is immoral but her plan to
tax two to three percent of their wealth
on an annual basis is clearly motivated
at least in part by a desire to reduce
their wealth and what she perceives as a
power imbalance in our society The
Economist's who helped Warren design her
plan have said that the idea is to make
rich people less wealthy if very rich
people have to pay a percentage of their
wealth and taxes each year
it makes it harder for them to maintain
their wealth in analyzing her plan they
wrote that one of the key motivations
for introducing a progressive wealth tax
is to curb the growing concentration of
wealth it's not really about raising tax
revenue it's about using government
power to make sure rich people have less
that much wealth is bad for our economy
and bad for our democracy Warren has
often pitched her plan as a way to raise
money from the ultra rich to pay for
more government benefits for everyone
else and on that count it's likely to
fall short Warren says her tax plan will
raise 2.75 trillion dollars over a
10-year period but other countries have
tried wealth taxes and found that they
raise far less money than expected in
1990 there were 12 osed nations with
wealth taxes similar to Warren's today
only four remain in Scandinavia of
course health care is right higher
education is 3 despite the tendency of
politicians like Bernie Sanders to hold
up Denmark and Sweden as Paragons of
democratic socialism that the US should
emulate the reality is that both Nix
their wealth taxes in the 1990s because
too many rich citizens were pulling
their money out of the country this
capital flight resulted in lower rates
of entrepreneurship and relative
economic stagnation not only did the
wealth tax hurt the economy it didn't
even raise the money it was supposed to
when Sweden eliminated its wealth tax it
had virtually no effect on government
finances France tried a wealth tax for
more than a decade starting in 2000 it
helped push an estimated 42,000
millionaires out of the country they
didn't pay the tax they just left but
Warren wants to get around the capital
flight problem by taxing the money no
matter where in the world it's located
and imposing a 40 percent exit tax on
anyone who wants to renounce his or her
citizenship we're gonna be out there
counting them and watching them what we
built right into the plan was far more
sophisticated
and more investment and the enforcement
warns plan relies on hiring more IRS
agents partly to deal with the
complexity of evaluating total
individual wealth but throwing more tax
collectors at the problem isn't going to
change the fact that the wealthy are
very good at protecting their money by
offshoring it or by putting it into
unique hard to value assets like artwork
Austria was one of the countries that
used to have a wealth tax one of the
reasons the country ended it was because
the cost of enforcement was so hot
based on its failure in other countries
and our vague proposals for addressing
those failures there's no compelling
evidence that warns ultra millionaire
tax will raise the revenue she claims
the wealth tax is best understood not as
a targeted revenue raiser but as a
symbolic declaration of opposition to
the existence of outsized wealth
regardless of how it was obtained what I
want is I want these billionaires to
stop being freeloaders Warren has
described the ultra millionaire tax as a
tool for addressing inequality but
really it's just a presidential
candidates way of saying I oppose the
existence of very rich people she could
have just said it
[Music]